Speaker 1: t said.
OK, join the discussion at David Pakman dotcom
slash Reddit.
That's already it.
Is Joe Biden abandoning the promised public
option.
CNBC is now reporting that Joe Biden's new
American families plan does not include the
promised expansion of Medicare eligibility,
and it doesn't include a provision allowing
the program to negotiate prices directly with
drug companies.
Dozens of Democratic lawmakers, CNBC rights
have urged Biden to include these provisions
in the second piece of his economic recovery
plan.
Biden's plan would make permanent premium
cuts for people buying insurance on the individual
market.
Key Democrats are aiming to include a public
option bill or create a separate one now that
Joe Biden is not including it in his recovery
plan.
Democratic Senators Patty Murray and Congressman
Frank Palone are going to write a bill to
create a public option.
President Joe Biden did run on expanding the
public insurance market, but this is not in
any of his plans.
So far, Republicans have exposed every effort,
have opposed every effort to expand government
managed health care.
Democrats would likely have to look at doing
this either via a budget reconciliation bill
to pass it without Republican support, because
you're not going to get Republican support
for a public option or convincing Joe Biden
to put it in one of his plans, including possibly
the American families plan.
There are lots of Democrats absolutely furious
with Joe Biden for not including this.
And I understand that.
And I'm with them now, you know that on this
program.
We are pragmatic and I would like to see the
promised public option done now.
I would like to see it done last month.
I would have like to see it done when Obamacare
was first put together.
I could understand if you said to me the inclusion
of the public option will never pass if you
make it part of this bill.
And so it makes sense for Joe Biden not to
include it.
I'm just not convinced of that yet.
I have not seen evidence that if Democrats
hold firm and go to Joe Biden and say, listen,
Joe, Republicans don't want the public option,
OK, we're going to need to pass it via a budget
reconciliation.
If we're to do it outside of this, let's just
include it.
Let's just include it now.
And if we do this all via budget reconciliation,
then we get the public option done and let's
actually put Republicans in a position to
vote against all of this stuff.
Now, the counter would be if you don't have
all 50 Democrats on board in the Senate.
Then it's not going to pass either way because
you're not going to get a single Republican
vote.
So this is one of those situations where there's
truth to both sides.
Do I believe that if Joe Biden doesn't do
the public option now, he never does it?
No, I think it's possible that Joe Biden would
try to do it later on.
But why wait?
Why wait?
There is no better time than now to do something.
And remember, the public option was the starting
negotiating point with Obamacare in 2010.
Should we should have had a better 2009?
Whenever the negotiations started, we should
have had a starting point that was far more
progressive with Obamacare.
The first thing to go was the public option
with Obamacare.
Is it possible Joe Biden will do this later?
Sure, yeah.
Maybe.
Let's just do it right now.
But you've got to have all 50 Democrats on
board.
It is not completely clear to me that you
have them.
So are the criticisms fair that it should
be done now?
Absolutely.
Is the criticism fair that this is evidence
Biden is permanently abandoning the public
option?
No, we can't say that yet.
We're four months into a four year term.
That being said, my preference would be to
do this right now.
There is no reason to wait unless you don't
have all 50 Democrats on board.
You've got to fight for their votes.
You have to negotiate with them.
If we find out.
That it is three Democratic senators that
don't want the public option, and were it
not for them, you could do all of this via
budget reconciliation.
I would say you've got to bring those three
people.
Joe Biden brags about being able to negotiate.
He brags about being able to get deals done
with the other side.
We'll get a deal done with your own side.
Get those three hypothetical senators who
don't want the public option in the American
families plan.
Bring them to the White House and convince
them, negotiate with them.
Do the thing that you ran on being able to
do as a diplomat and an elected official and
a dealmaker in the Senate for a long time.
Could it be done in three months?
Could it be done in six months?
Could it be done in 2022?
Sure.
But I would like to see it done right now.
And until I see evidence that it couldn't
be done right now, I believe we need to continue
pushing for it to be done.
Now, many of you will write in and say, David,
this is pathetic.
You just got to do Medicare for all.
Many Democratic senators don't support Medicare
for all, and neither does Joe Biden.
Medicare for all is not going to happen right
now.
OK, so what's on the table is can we get a
public option done?
An idea would be get some Democrats to lobby
for Medicare for all in this bill and negotiate
to a public option.
I would be open to that.
But I don't want is something that has no
chance of passing.
If that's the case, we don't know that to
be the case yet.
If there's no chance of passing, there's no
point in holding this bill up indefinitely.
But I've not seen the work done yet.
That proves to me you can't force a public
option into this bill right now.
If you disagree with me, let me know and we'll
have more coverage of the coverage of this
on our Instagram page, which you can find
at David Pakman show on Instagram.
While you're there, follow me on Instagram
at David Pakman.